the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay good afternoon good afternoon I
want to remind you that a week from
today is the second exam the format is
identical to what you had 50 multiple
choice questions thirty from the book
chapters five to seven twenty from sacks
and the lectures short answers okay
so talking about tests you know why do
we have tests we live that you live in a
world of tests you know everything from
SATs to on your horizons maybe GRE Zoar
or MCATs or LSAT so so why do people
have tests besides making it miserable
to be under 30 as a revenge of the older
people right okay why do people have
tests yeah
yeah one of them is just you know
yeah verify that you know something when
people will call that sort of have you
learned stuff right the test is a meant
to be an estimate of what have you
learned but a second form of testing
that that's what people sometimes will
call high-stakes tests in a slightly
different way our ones about selection
and prediction which sometimes involve
achievement or aptitude things like SATs
or GRE is right so achievement sirs are
meant to be estimates of what you know
how much math advanced placement tests
how much math you know or physics
content in a given area and sort of a
broader sense of aptitude SATs or GREs
now one thing that's different about
today's lecture and intelligence it'll
be a little someone we do personalities
up until now to a first approximation
most of the time we've talked about
louis view as general principles of the
human mind and brain across everybody
right how vision works across everybody
memory across everybody thinking across
everybody and now we're switching to a
domain and it doesn't have to be this
way but this is the way the world has
done it where we emphasize differences
between people right so when people take
tests it's not to see that everybody
took the test what they're going to do
is you get an A or a B or a C or you get
a high SAT or a medium SAT right and
schools use the differences to think
about you and so one question is you
know from an empirical sense are these
tests pretty good at predicting things
and the answer is you know they're
decent they're not terrific okay so the
tests survive like SATs or GREs because
there's correlations between these kinds
of tests before you get to graduate
school for example and how faculty rate
students or how productive people are in
terms of researches or as a graduate
student in this case or the GPAs or
things like that so and the correlations
are about you know 0.3 to 0.4 to give
you an intuitive sense the correlation
is between sex and height whether you're
men or women and height is about 0.4 so
of course lots of women are taller than
lots of men an average men are taller
than women that's a point for Coral
so you know this is in that range right
okay so tests are pretty good predictors
everybody says that for things like
predicting college performance or
graduate school performance the
combination of tests and grades are
better
the difference is grades take a lot of
years to produce you know tests are one
traumatic outing right so you know so
they're you know tests are just a part
of our life in selection processes so
now what is intelligence and it's it's
it's a loaded word right I mean memory
is kind of a neutral or detention is a
neutral word intelligence is a loaded
word I mean nobody wants to be low on
intelligence right and so um you know
psychologists have come out of this way
but it's kind of funny because there's
not going to be a really deep definition
maybe it's a lot of different things and
how they average up or something like
that but people have said well it's
something about the ability to solve
problems to understand and learn complex
material to adapt to the environment
mental quickness those are all senses
you might have of something that you
think of as intelligence in a person but
you know whether they are one thing many
things it's very hard to pull that out
and we don't know too much about that
really and I also want to remind you of
something we talked about but it's
especially important in this field we
talked about an experiment versus
correlations an experiment you have to
have a dependent measure something you
measure but critically and uniquely of
an independent variable something that
you vary that's what makes a study and
experiment as opposed to correlation so
studies of intelligence and of every
kind are almost always correlational and
almost never experimental that means
they're always subject to lots of
interpretation and many factors in the
world and that's very important to keep
in mind you know so and again they tend
to focus on variation in people rather
than what is intelligence itself and
again here's this another correlation of
height and weight you know that has a
pretty stronger correlation right so
where where did intelligence start with
it's a fascinating story and by the way
let me tell you the SAT story on the
sidebar from
moment so SATs nowadays do people some
people get ready a lot for SATs by
courses you take and things like that I
read about that okay when I when I took
it people weren't that organized but but
getting into college wasn't that
competitive so you know and the original
goals of SATs was what do you know it's
really interesting because it ends up
being things that they say well because
people who are maybe under more
supported circumstances more financially
advantageous circumstances get more help
to get ready for the SAT those things
might amplify SAT differences in a way
that's not really about the person to
start with the original goal of the SATs
was to the national test that was fair
for everybody so that schools like
Harvard for example attended to admit
the same kind of students from the same
small set of schools in the Northeast so
now we have a test for everybody across
the country and we can admit people on
their merit rather than a small social
connectivity networks that make sense
okay and yet SATs are now viewed as a
suspicious tool in that regard it was
originally meant to be democratizing
saying everybody in the country takes
the same test it's not whether you have
a connection through a network to to our
University IQs had the same story for
good reasons and we'll talk about that
IQ tests and interpretations of IQ are
often sort of not don't have a good
history but the original goal was pretty
reasonable so in in France in 1904 they
began Universal elementary education
that every child goes to class and
Albert Binet a physician wanted an
objective way to identify children who
needed extra help perfectly good idea
child comes to school some children are
ready to go some children need a lot of
extra help because they have a
difficulty so he gave developed a set of
tests where he probed many different
abilities like copying and drawing
repeating digits recognizing coins
explaining why a statement did not make
sense they wanted to probe different
little areas of abilities so if a child
is terrible at something or two things
the teacher knows this child needs some
extra help to get going so that's a you
know that's a good use of testing I
think by everybody's criterion but then
testing you know sort of took off IQ
testing but I I Q stands for
intelligence quotient
a test to give typical children they
give it often for the most commonly used
IQ tests at many different ages they'll
test a large number of individuals and
they'll compare what nowadays what they
think of as your mental age to your
chronological age right so your
chronological age is how long you've
lived your mental ages how well you
score in a test the most famous IQ test
and most widely-used takes about two
hours of testing comes from David wek so
the Wechsler adult intelligence scale
one for children and within that test
what's within that test because when
people talk about tests I think whatever
kind of test it is it could only be
about as good as the test design itself
right to the extent that it's any good
right a ridiculous test is a ridiculous
test even if society gives it to you
right but tests can be better than that
and so what is inside the most widely
used IQ test into especially in clinical
environments so let's talk about one of
them it has a bunch of little tests when
is vocabulary they asked you to define
words that similarities Alaska serious
questions like how are an airplane and
the car alike very simple map arithmetic
operations digits pants how many digits
can you remember information they'll
give you a series of questions like who
is Martin Luther King jr. comprehension
they'll ask you things about the world
like why are their taxes and things like
that and you give an answer somebody
scribbles down what you say and they
score you you know you got two points at
one point we'll talk about that and then
they add up these scores in the sub test
what's in the soap none a non verbal
test or the performance tests they'll
show you a picture with a think missing
have you did that as a kid I love those
things you know what's missing in the
picture stuff like that blocks they'll
have you rearrange them into various
geometric design picture arrangement you
get a cartoon panels and you have to put
them in the correct order to tell a
story and they measure how accurately
and quickly you do these things there's
nothing amazing about any of these
things they're probing a variety of
little abilities that you have and again
that will take the mental age and
chronological age divide it multiply by
100 and they'll standardize it so that
100 is the population mean in the United
States do other countries do these
things as well is that okay
so I mean a test can only be possibly
good as the content of it and what it
measures it doesn't measure depends on
the specific content of it they'll scale
the scores out so you have a normal
distribution you know with a peak in the
middle the raw score is the number you
get the standardized wanted to adjust it
for your age and it's a pretty important
concept because we'll come back to this
in a moment right the raw scores your
actual score but then they adjust it for
your age right because you don't expect
a five-year-old to do as well as a
fifteen-year-old to do as well as you
know peak 18 to 23 year olds okay and
then bad things happen as you get older
you you know tell you a bit about that
to a 2/3 of the people are plus or minus
one standard deviation they set it for
that more than two standard deviations
up or down are about 5% on either end of
the distribution of scores and they norm
it by age again you don't expect a
six-year-old to do something but you get
some funny things not they have to worry
about this in detail but let me just
gives you a sense so imagine your
five-year-old and you take the test on
the last day you're a five-year-old or
imagine you have your birthday today and
you're six years old by moving from five
to six from you know Wednesday to
Thursday you've moved up a year for the
scoring right because they go by year
not by day so if you would have scored
120 on the IQ test yesterday when they
say what should you have scored for a
five-year-old the very same test the
next day you would score 100 okay now
it's a bit of a that's the extreme case
but you understand what happens right
because you here's how well you did that
might have been pretty good 120 is above
the average for a five-year-old but the
next day you're a six-year-old now for
six-year-old is just average okay
so age has a big effect on these things
here's here's something sad for aging
but good for you that your be smart now
a 40 year old who scores average with
what would be a what do you know
undergrad right if I if I score like you
know let me rephrase as if you were
compared to 40 year old you would have a
and that you have a hundred IQ you would
have a 230 IQ because age knocks down
the score as well okay
so things go up and and things go down
okay
in this problem and usually they think
of a score below seventy as clinically
concerning as this is not now and top
two percent you get to join Mensa and do
whatever it meant so people do which I
don't know exactly but sounds
interesting okay an important thing
about tests of any kind are two huge
concepts reliability and validity so
reliability refers to the ideas that if
you were tested more than once you would
get the same score the better IQ tests
work a fair bit to try to achieve that
validity is you know the deeper question
does a test validly measure what it's
supposed to measure so if we had you
flip a coin and said that's your IQ
you'd say you know that's ridiculous
it's not a valid test right we could
measure your height that would be
extremely reliable measuring the same
height today as tomorrow if we did a
decent job
that wouldn't be a valid measure of
anything about any mental ability
nevermind something like intelligence so
those are two important concepts and
testing but very different now why do
people think IQ tests are interesting
besides just this weird curiosity about
intelligence because IQ tests correlate
with GPA and high school and college job
success salary stable marriages staying
out of jail and how long you live
alright again it's a correlation it
could be many different things you know
think I want to talk you out of is the
idea that if you have you know a 200 IQ
today you've got something stored up
that will fend off disease right it's
not that necessarily it's that there's
lots of things in your life that got you
to that score and all those things are
likely to persist in your life good
health supportive education
interest maybe in taking on challenging
tasks you had those before you had them
while you took the test you continued to
have them after another way to think
about it though which is you know both
the plus and a minus being how you look
at it
IQ scores account for approximately 25
percent of the variation on these things
so that's not huge that means there's
many many many other factors besides
whatever IQ is capturing but it's a it's
about as big a chunk as you can get for
a couple hours of testing and we know
two other things like personality
variation education culture all those
things blend in and how a person will do
an IQ all these outcomes
so when we go back and forth because in
one hand we say there's a lot of stuff
besides IQ but IQ has some interesting
this otherwise nobody would talk about
it and would just disappear from the
world so on average on average what is
15 minutes 15 IQ points mean so an
average a person with a hundred IQ in
the US will go to high school in a year
or two in a community college on average
these are averages of a huge variety of
people yet 15 more IQ points and on
average you're likely to finish college
and have a white-collar job have 15
fewer points and you're not likely to
complete high school and you'd have to
have a job that doesn't require
education background so 15 points on
averages correlate with things here's
another one because we're all you know
we're going to come everybody in the end
is a little bit curious in your own life
how much of you know what you're good at
or not good at or any of us comes from
our genes from our environment you know
where does that come from what what what
are the things that support us or limit
us so here's one study that's took women
from the same family so they're all
sisters from the same family okay
they're trying to control a little bit
of genetics because the shared genes
within the family they're not twins but
it and definitely shared environment
they're in the same household so it's
true okay and within those families they
look at the IQ score so here's the
average group above average well above
average a little below average a lot
below average and they say that in these
these women all coming from the same
households here's their average income
and here's the average rate of
illegitimate births which is one measure
that people think is kind of a social an
average not a desired outcome to have a
child without a family supporting that's
not going to help a person succeed in
the world to be a single mother and so
you can see you know the salary pretty
much moves with the IQ on average and
the rate of village' births pretty much
moves with that too so again it's an
average but there's some relationship
between these things now if you pick up
the newspaper today and read about you
know nuclear disasters in Japan and
problems in the Middle East
and other things like that you would say
it's hard to say the world is getting
smarter but you will you may or may not
be surprised to hear of the so-called
Flint effect this was kind of a surprise
Minh was discovered which is basically
this IQ scores where they're measured go
up around the world all the time by IQ
test scores it's as if the world is
getting smarter all the time which is
kind of an optimistic thing okay whether
it's getting wiser right is a good
question but spike by IQ score smarter
all the time
so that's hidden for many years because
every every few years these tests get re
normed for the group so that makes sense
okay so there you're given again hundred
is the average and then given again and
100 is the average but if they ignore
this averaging and just say across these
tests that only change a little bit some
of them only change a little bit if we
just take the scores look at 1930 1940
and it just keeps going on so this is a
Flynn is the person who discovered that
the world is getting smarter by raw IQ
tests and one of the tests a usable show
an example this is another widely used
test called Ravens progressive matrices
IQs go up about three points every ten
years so if you were born in 1930 you
would you know first would have an IQ of
100 their child 108 and their grandchild
120 with a standard deviation higher so
it's like smarter smarter smarter now
you will be I don't recommend to go home
and tell your parents but any debate you
have with them is pointless because
you're smarter than they are but by the
f you if push comes to shove ax you can
look up the Flynn effect and have a
discussion about that so somebody you
know who has an IQ today let's flip it
around the grandparent with if you have
a hundred your grandparent you know
would have a IQ of 82 by this reasoning
people in 1900 would have a mean IQ of
70 by okay and and nobody knows why it's
going up all over the world there's all
kinds of ideas about maybe nutrition is
going up maybe reasoning abilities are
being Porsche
maybe educational things I mean it's
impossible scientifically to know why
because it's happening on such a global
giant scale but some people have said
the tests don't go up uniform
across the test which gives us a hint
about the way the world is changing and
how intelligence tests in some way
become a barometer of what mental
abilities are increasingly prized by
societies so there's relatively small
gains across years in vocabulary or
general knowledge or arithmetic whether
our large gains are what you might call
abstract thinking tasks like
similarities so let's focus on that for
a moment so a similarities question
might be like this in what way are dogs
and rabbits alike if you answer both
mammals you get two points okay that's
the best you can do and that's what we
would call an abstract or taxonomic one
whether you're abstracting across the
two things or you could give an answer
like you use dogs to hunt rabbits okay
that's not a wrong answer that's
considered a one-point answer you kind
of seem to know what a dog is you kind
of seem to know where rabbit but you
didn't give the best answer by this test
criterion because it's a functional
description of these things not a
abstract conceptual one so let's think
about different societies besides the
Western industrialized one you know that
we represent mostly in Liberia they ask
people to sort baskets of food tools
containers and clothing so most of us
you know Western educated in a very
broad sense would you know put the
things of food together the things of
tools together those are the abstract
categories the people from this tribe
put them in terms of functional pairings
they put the potato next to the knife
they used to peel the potato right and
here's the fun thing in this study they
said what would a fool do with this and
they said oh well a fool would put all
the food things together and all the
utensils together but that's pointless
to do that because you know what are you
to do all the food things over here when
the utensils are over here do you
understand okay it's what our society
emphasizes as a useful way of thinking
right so you could it's not completely
arbitrary but it's not arbitrarily
rewarded and prized in the world of
Education that we live in here so
intelligence tests attach value to at a
specific time and specific test scores
are changing over time different
cultures are
valuing different things it's constantly
renormalize it used to be for some
number of years that 70 was used as the
cutoff for estimates of broadly speaking
mental retardation and why that matters
is that a person for example would get
certain kinds of medical services
provided to them when a new version of
the Wisc of the Wechsler test came out
in 1991 so a renormalize used that new
test when it came out which they didn't
quite but if they had the number of
people rated as [ __ ] diagnosed as
[ __ ] would have doubled in a single
day because the renown the norms aren't
pushing the numbers up okay so that the
number of people call it you know
scoring very poorly would have doubled
in a single day because of the
renormalize idea this is very important
to realize that all these things what's
really in the test was valued by a sort
of society or culture and this norming
things are really influencing a lot of
how you get to these numbers so ideas
about intelligence roughly in the in
this field have come out of what are
called psychometric analysis of subjects
they give you this scatter of tests and
the thing that struck many people is how
for a given individual there's
correlations among the tests a person
who does one well in one test tends to
do well in another test and tends to do
well on a third test and a researcher
named Spearman gave this this
correlation among tests the letter G the
name G to Stanford general intelligence
and asked for specific intelligence and
then since then many people have said
well really is there one broad sense of
intelligence are there multiple separate
kinds of intelligence and people debate
that in the field and probably the some
one that the answer is it depends what
you're measuring for and the purpose of
the measurement but in a good one to
look at because it's very clear as a
difference between fluid and
crystallized intelligence so fluid
intelligence is what we think of as
novel problem-solving you have a
situation you were never in before what
do you do Christoph's intelligence are
you know information you know so here's
the conceptual idea that maybe general
intelligence is you know a thing and
then it shows up on different tests with
a different specific intelligences like
maybe verbal or arithmetic so let me
show the fluid and crystallized one
so again fluid is processes so the fluid
one we said we're first mental processes
that are applied for novel situation and
that declines a lot with age and
adulthood so these lines going down here
you know I'm about here and you're about
here who should be grading who in this
course you might ask okay
all right the only reason the only
reason that I get to grade you is
because these lines keep going up here
this is how many facts you know all
right so the plus of living longer is
that you get to know more stuff the risk
of living longer is you don't use it as
flexibly under novel situations all
right so pretty strong this distinction
at least with ageing between fluid and
soaked a fluid intelligent crystallized
intelligence there's another study of
exactly the same thing
it's a striking ski slope of decline in
fluid intelligence look at this all
right from about 20 to 80 it just goes
down relentlessly but when it comes to
crystallized intelligence things like
vocabulary that kind of hangs in there a
puzzle you have some big health problem
so at least those two kinds of seem to
have a different basis and people have
thought about different ways to think
about intelligence and I'll just tell
you that you can generally get positive
correlations among the tests and so
often people think about this general
intelligence the correlation among the
tests is a best single predictor okay
now there's lots of responses to ideas
about intelligence one of them is study
of emotional intelligence
Peter salivate is the researcher most
involved in that you know and we know
this in everyday life right we know
smart people what we might call book
smart people who you know make who seem
unwise and how they relate to people
right how they perceive emotions how
they facilitate with thought with
emotion how they understand or manage
their emotions how they relate to other
people and so you know it's common sense
to think that as something that varies
across people it's very hard to measure
that I mean part of the tyranny of tests
is what can be measured gets measured
what's hard to measure is hard to
measure right it's very hard to measure
in a laboratory in an hour a person's
emotional intelligence people have tried
it's just hard to do here's another area
that's gotten a lot of attention from
Howard Gardner at Harvard kind of
fighting back against this idea of a
single form of intelligence as captured
by GE the idea of multiple intelligences
and looking at things that dissociations
in patience development that you know we
can talk about linguistic intelligence
spatial intelligence music intelligence
bodily intelligence at great athletes
have great bodily intelligence intra
personal or interpersonal it's kind of
like emotional existential okay so he
said there's all these different kinds
of intelligence and you can each person
is a profile of these you know you can
be really strong in one a medium and
another and not so strong in another the
problem with this hall approach is yes
it's true that people have a huge
variety of facets of their humanity this
whole course I feel like every lecture
we do is we just turn a person a little
bit to study another facet of their
humanity right but it's hard as heck to
measure you know interpersonal
intelligence or naturalistic
intelligence now maybe somebody will
figure out how to do that it's just hard
to measure those things even if it feels
like something conceptually that's there
and so it's been hard so this idea which
has had a lot of resonance to people not
liking very simple-minded ideas of
intelligence very unitary ones it's to
still not gain much traction in
practical use so let me talk a bit about
some of the things that people said well
if we talk about this intelligence what
might be some mental mechanisms or
neural mechanisms that support or
underlie a so some things that go with
it our mental speed and you know this
right kind of quickness of thought okay
not even big thoughts just quickness it
feels like it helps a person solve
problems so for example is a moderately
high correlation between IQ complicated
tests of all those tests and how quickly
you push a button when the light comes
on now we never say wow you know Sally
or Fred is really smart they can push a
button when the light comes on really
fast you know let's go to them and get
the
answers for the problem set okay because
I'm you know it doesn't seem but that
would go with the idea that simply being
fast is kind of a useful thing for for
acting on the world or how quickly
people decide whether two lights two
lines are the same length or different
lengths very simple thing just speed and
another idea is working memory capacity
how much information you can hold in
your head at any one time that's
relevant to the problem or task in front
of you so people try to explore these in
certain ways I'm going to talk to you
about a couple of brain studies that
have tried to look at this so again we
talked last time about frontal cortex
different parts of it and especially the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex is
involved in thinking and so people have
taken tasks and said you know what
happens when you think about them so
here's one of easy item on the so-called
cattell culture fair test so you know
which of these things goes into here
there's harder once okay so you you can
okay or here's a sulli
slightly adaptive version of the Ravens
progressive matrices all you think about
that for a moment I don't remember which
is so you're told here's some rows and
columns one of these eight answers
logically fits in here and it's your job
to figure out which one let's see how do
we like three I like three two yeah is
that threesome okay okay all right okay
and they they get this is a medium hard
item on this kind of a test and then
they do these kind of map of results and
they say this is the what's fun about
the Ravens that's the item you just saw
which is they they sort of look at lots
of other tests so specifically spatial
tests specifically verbal tests
specifically math tests and they said if
we have to give you one test only one
test only what test would best predict
your performance on all the other tests
and the answer is Ravens or IQ tests
like that so of course if I give you a
math test that better predicts your math
performance if I give you a verbal test
that better predicts your verbal
performance if I give you a spatial test
that better predicts your special
performance but if I want to give you
one test that gives me the best
prediction of your performance and other
tests
it's things like these IQ tests that do
that and that's that's just empirical
that's not an argument about values or
what intelligence is it's a lot of the
people who work in this field they don't
even care about these arguments they
just say I just want to test that
predicts ok it's your job if you wanted
to figure out why it is it's the genes
environment education whatever I just
want to test that predicts so from that
perspective these tests are have a
strong history and what turns on the
brain when you solve this kind of a task
well frontal cortex a lot parietal
cortex but especially frontal cortex so
it goes with our idea that thinking is
very much tied to prefrontal cortical
function here's another example of a
study that said let's compare what
happens in the brain when you have tests
items that are hard which is the outlier
one here they require a lot of G where
items that are easy they require very
little G we'll compare in the brain you
know what happens when you turn on your
G so to speak and again the prominent
areas tend to be for both spatial and
verbal prefrontal cortex one more so
n-back task we use that a lot where you
job is letters come on and in this one
the one back you say when do I see a
letter that's the same letter as the one
before so for exact sort so you see our
rmx this is two back because an M occur
two items ago three backs are really
hard because the letter is going boom
boom boom boom and what's hard about it
is the letter in front of you you have
to say does it match the one I saw three
letters previously press remember that
because it's going to be the target for
the one that comes three after does this
it's hard okay I can tell you it's hard
you can be smart it's pretty hard and
for this task in general the harder it
gets the more you turn on dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex and so they do this
task with students in Washington st.
Louis related it to performance on the
Ravens and sure enough in the brain it's
again prefrontal cortex alright so a
bunch of studies has found all these
tests
you know involve a fair bit of the brain
but they seem to really draw upon the
capacities that you and I have in
prefrontal cortex and one more note in
brain imaging when we talk about things
sometimes it's better to
more activation and sometimes less
activation and you have to know the
behavior to know that so whenever you
see somebody saying oh this person this
group or whatever had more brain
activity or less brain activity you
don't know until you know the rest of
the behavior whether more is good or bad
sometimes when people get really good at
something they use less of their brain
because they can do it so efficiently
okay so here's an example of people with
lower and higher IQ doing an end back
task and you can see that the people
with lower IQ have much more activation
in the people at higher IQ so it's as if
these people have to use all their brain
resources to accomplish this and these
people only have to use some it's as if
it were that so you know here comes the
you know when the classic topics of the
fate of a human how much does your genes
at birth and how much is the environment
that you're in and if you were really to
understand that in a deep deep
scientific way we would know the genes
that are related to intelligence the
experiential factors in the world family
education emotional support and so on
how they interact all those things we
know practically nothing about I'll show
you one tiny example we know practically
nothing about them in any depth at all
so we mostly end up using twin studies
to make the best estimates we can
because we which doesn't tell you what
the factors are it just tells you how
much is a twin who's identical more or
less alike than a twin who's fraternal
okay we'll come back to that but I do
want to tell you a sort of exciting
direction that's slightly getting at the
genetic story of this so you may know
many of you more than I do about
genetics but single nucleotide
polymorphisms our DNA variations these
occur relatively commonly they're
estimated to make up about 90% of human
genetic variation and they're constant
from generation to generation so people
have studied a few of these variations
among people and related them to
performance so let me remind you of
something from last lecture the
Wisconsin card sorting task where you
sort of these cards mysteriously and we
said that if you have a frontal lesion
you do poorly on this tasks you get
stuck with one kind of problem-solving
or have it answer even when it's wrong
in a new circumstance so what people
have done is look at one particular gene
that's related to this enzyme that
modulates dopamine function in the
prefrontal cortex so it's a risk factor
for schizophrenia it metabolizes
dopamine in prefrontal cortex it's a-you
know we vary whether were which version
of this gene we have and here's the
performance on the card sorting task let
me pick these these are healthy people
if you have this version of the gene or
this pairing or this pairing here's your
card sorting task going up so this is
kind of amazing that we're close to that
where a single gene variant now the
score doesn't go up a lot it accounts a
small percent of the variance but it's
one gene having an identifiable
correlation with performance on a
demanding task and you can do this end
back kind of task we just talked about
and then you can look in the brain as
people are performing this divided by
which version of this gene they have and
what you get is more activation in the
people with with this compliment than
this compliment
sort of consistent with the idea other
working harder there's the same group of
people who are performing less well in
the card sorting tasks so there are some
genes that have been in a fight that are
associated with what we call met called
broadly intelligence but that one gene
only counts for a tiny bit of the
overall score on these kinds of things
and we don't know much more about it
than that so how do people even begin to
think about nature and nurture and you
know I like to think about this in two
ways one way is narrowly IQ tests
because there's been so much work in
that area but it's you know it's a deep
question of how do we get to be who we
are so again they mostly look at twin
studies so-called behavioral genetics
and estimated heritability how much of
variation is due to genetics I'll come
back to this height thing but to give
you a sense height is thought to be 90%
heritable in the US okay
tall parents on average have love taller
kids less tall parents less Hopkins and
in twin studies they contrast
monozygotic twins twins that are
identical or have the same genes with
dizygotic ones who share some genes but
not nearly as many
of course they share the same
environment a lot have you guys seen the
two twins talking to each other video on
YouTube so that's all if you haven't
seen it it's kind of fun the two twins
are babbling but they're so
demonstrative it's as if they were
talking to each other in babble right
it's kind of fun if you haven't seen
it's very cute okay all right anyway and
this is you know the here's again is
that the the the fraternal twins and
here's the identical twins before
they're born so here are this has been
studied a fair bit here's the
correlations between IQ scores and
people of varying relations so let's
just work down on that list unrelated
persons reared together
so perhaps an adopted person and his or
her sibling or something they're
correlated of about what point two okay
foster parent and child it goes up a
little bit parent and child living
together so that's a biological parent a
child living together that goes up a
fair bit brother and sister reared apart
back down brother and sister we're
together so you could look at this as
brother you know kind of shared genes
right and that this might be something
like environment that makes sense
intuitively okay that's assuming there's
no interaction between genes and
environment which we know must happen so
when I do this I'm treating them as if
they were additive and independent
everything we know about genes and the
environments are tremendously
interactive okay we just don't have
insight into that in any deep way in
humans here's a really stunning one
identical twins reared apart seventy
point seven correlation identical twins
reared apart that suggests a huge
influence of genes identical twin ones
we were together 90.9 okay so these this
is the finding that stunned people so
look at identical twins reared apart
they're they're much more like each
other than a brother and a sister we're
together who share all the same
environment of Education parental
support and other things so you know I'm
going to come back to this but as best
people can estimate and these are you
know these might be radically replaced
as we deepen our understanding of the
actual genes and the actual
environmental factors but people are
estimating it's about half and half for
IQ tests and we discussed the bit of
arbitrariness in that
so about half and a half let me show you
a couple of environmental influences
that have been identified and you know
the first two months of specs has to do
with on average with something about the
healthiness of the environment the child
is born into the third one is kind of
fun just to talk about because you may
wonder if you have a sibling or no
sibling you know what does it mean that
you were first born or second born or
third born okay at least statistically
okay so let's do the first two here's
breastfeeding 3,000 people were followed
from birth to young adulthood
breastfeeding for at least six months
correlate with a five to seven point IQ
game so we said 15 points really seems
to mean something in educational
outcomes the five to seven is you know
half of that so that's something right
so let's talk about for a minute you
could say and I can tell you the as a
parent who fairly recently uh had
children you know all the mothers in the
u.s. that I know of are going like I've
got a breast feed and get that my kid to
MIT Oh two more months of breastfeeding
and this kid could go all the way to
tenured faculty right all right so so I
could tell you there's a lot of pressure
on mothers if you don't know this not my
mother I mean that but now mother's here
you know do this for your kid do this
for your kid do this for your kid all
right
because of results like these so one
possibility is there something in breast
milk that would be the direct mechanism
that's making kids smarter give me
another possibility that has nothing to
do with the breast milk yeah
it could be more nurturing sir children
in many ways they could be mothers who
can stay home and spend some time with
the children versus being under very
pressured economic circumstances that
prohibit that right it could be a lot of
things that seem does that make sense
okay we don't know nobody has shown yet
that it's the breast milk that goes into
your brain and pushes up your brain okay
in any sense it's just a correlation and
of course if you're a parent you're
going to say I'm not going to I'll take
my I'll do the breastfeeding and let the
scientist figure out in the future right
alright here's another one there's the
birth weight so again you could say the
same thing I mean certainly you know
having very low birth weight is a big
risk factor for lots of things but at
birth weight again goes with many
factors in the environment that are
supportive for a healthy pregnancy
versus not okay so it doesn't mean it is
the birth weight it could be all the
other things that were in the
environment you know during the
pregnancy at birth and continue on
average in the environment of that child
throughout their childhood and young
educators that make sense okay if
they're born in a very unsupportive
medical environment they might have a
low birth weight and unless our parents
win the lottery or something they're
likely to be in a difficult environment
for all their educational years to come
so people have tried to make clearer
because it's so easy to get into sort of
little mental traps on genes versus
environments how genetic diversity
affects heritability so there's a couple
different ways to do it let's do this
one so imagine you had cloned tomato
plants that means they all have the
exact same genes in this hypothetical
example but somebody has poor soil
somebody has good soil well you get big
differences and the heritability will be
zero right environment can have huge
influences but if you have genetically
diverse plants you know then you're
going to have an interaction so some
plants will do okay even in poor soil
some plants will do you know most
spectacularly in good soil and less
spectacular like environment by genes
interactions and you can see that's in
so many different ways so here's one
example so we said height is 90%
heritable within a society but Japanese
men in the u.s. of people with Japanese
extract our three inches taller than
people in Japan okay so they still have
weight whatever with Japanese genes are
they have Japanese genes but in the u.s.
getting the u.s.
diet of McDonald's and that's pushing
them up your 3 inches okay so so what do
we mean by her so it just really know
what do we fight is heritable but
environment is a big part of the story
okay so it's just both I mean now here's
a fun study and a reason that if you're
a younger sibling I and you desperately
want to IQ points you might knock off
your older sibling all right I don't
recommend this this is tongue-in-cheek
all right but but it's a kind of a fun
study just thinking about birth order
more in a fun way well look at the whole
thing we're talking about from 99 to 104
so it's five points we're talking about
but whether it but in some countries
they sort of test everybody going into
the military and this was done and I
think this is it on Denmark right and
what they said is here's first person
here's here's somebody who had these who
are all children these are the IQ scores
and this is the IQ scores if you if it
you're that you would have but what
happens if your older sibling has passed
away sadly you get those points and
here's a here's a person who's older
sibling and older sibling passed away
and they move up those points that is if
you're a younger sibling you have a few
lower IQ points okay it's an average but
kind of strikingly if your older sibling
passes away sadly you seem to get those
IQ points as you move up the birth order
yeah yes yeah when you're young
yeah it's too late sorry for all of you
in here you know too late okay all right
it's only a couple of points also but
this guy did science because people are
always wondering about there's an
infused curiosity that birth order
you know consequences so here's a person
these are at least uh anyway okay so um
but let's talk about a little bit about
that birth order again because there's a
second really interesting point so uh
here's Ravens score and here's if you if
you're a lone child one of two that
second of two children the third of
three the fourth of four the eighth of
eight the ninth of ninth you can see
this course keep going down it's not
dramatic but larger families and you can
have a million ideas about why that
would be alright
about why it is larger your family and
if the further you're down on the list
you lose a few I quit you point
for every sibling who's older okay so
here's one idea from Robert science it
was a very creative psychologist we're
not sure that it's right but I think
it's really fun to think about
yeah so here here was this idea he said
I'm going to make up an idea which is
this the firstborn
maybe's exposed only to adults the
adults are talking to them about you
know the news of the day and all kinds
of things the second-born has two adults
let's say in a typical family but also
has an older sibling right so the
intellectual environment will be the
average of two adults and a little child
the next one and so on so he said you
can do a kind of a formula which is like
this pretend the two parents are each 30
and you're born will call your family
intellectual stimulating environment 30
because we'll add up the ages and divide
by the number of people in the family
that make sense this is this is not
meant to be a real formula okay it's
just a conceptual playing out and then
he said okay now you have the two
parents and you have four-year-old
sibling because you're the second born
so now it's four of you we divide by
four we'll say the average intellectual
thing in the family sixteen by the time
the next child comes along a
seven-year-old sibling three-year-old
sibling divided by five and the average
intellectual environment is fourteen
here's the idea on average it's better
for a child to have lots of interaction
with a parent than with a little kid
because a parent will stimulate more
than a little kid a little sibling might
be a lot of fun okay but in purely IQ
land parent two parents talking to you
about stuff is a more educational
environment and two parents plus a
sibling who's two years older than you
because the two-year-old can't help no
matter how smart he or she is they can't
talk with you like an adult this is the
thought and now here's the really fun
observation and again we don't really
know this is exactly right but but you
know every year if you're around issues
of Education there's test scores that
different states have and in this test
test scores go up and you took you have
taken high-stakes tests right in high
schools and grade schools and stuff okay
if the test scores goes up everybody
goes oh you know reelect us
we're awesome administration our test
scores are going up we're doing
everything right right if the test
scores go down they go Oh throw the
bubbles out of the administration their
kids are watching too much MTV turn off
that computer and so on right everybody
gets a test scores and they figure out
you know who's good and who's bad right
you know parents teachers school systems
politicians whatever science says and
this is kind of an interesting thought
he says no he can predict whether it's
scores will go up or down simply by on
average in a given year whether you
there are more first Born's or second
borns or third borns that if he just
takes that population average of every
kid the moment they're born he can
predict years later where the scores go
and so here's the here's the scores in
Iowa of the actual scores are going up
and down so you can imagine scores are
going down everybody's really upset
about you know kids who don't study and
teachers who don't teach and parents who
don't parent write scores are going off
and the kids are awesome the teachers
are awesome the parents are awesome
because that's who gets the credit right
and he's saying ah this is my prediction
here they simply on the number you know
for a given birth year the average
number of older children in your family
okay that's it I'll look how well that
tracks it's unbelievable right so it
just makes you rethink that's so often
when we get information about Society of
what's going on this may or not be right
or this may be right or wrong but we
don't really know what's going on you
know there's all kinds of huge things
out there in the world that aren't the
easiest things to blame or give credit
to right okay so there there's smart
little small differences but they seem
to track interestingly in the number of
siblings you have who are older than you
and at the same time this idea of
parental exposure to language you know
there's this Wiley study why decided
study from Hart and Risley so they
recorded for each month for two and a
half years heroic recording one full
hour of every word spoken at home
between parents and children and 42 just
42 families but they categorize them as
high medium or low socioeconomically so
in terms of income and education okay
and they're recording lots and lots of
conversations verbatim and they code and
analyze every utterance in thirteen
hundred transcripts of thirty thousand
pages all right this is what the reason
why this has not done a lot it's not
very glamorous work to do
alright you can imagine sitting down
there but they're coding they recording
lots of conversations at home and
families who are better off medium off
or poor and they're looking at what is
the conversation like for an hour a day
and here's what they find that variation
in children's IQ and language abilities
related to the amount of the appearance
speak to their children and the academic
success by age eight or nine or ten is
related a lot to speech at zero to three
now again you think causally because you
think parents are talking to you at zero
at 3:00 at nine and ten you're doing
differential equations causally know the
parents are talking to you a lot zero to
three are talking to you at four or five
and six a lot most of the time okay so
these things are not like you get an
injection you're done many of the
factors that we can measure continue on
average for most people in their
environment but it's very impressive how
the environment altogether influences
things by age three that cumulative act
vocabulary is 1100 words in a
professional family and a child was a
child 750 in a working class and 500 and
a welfare family and welfare families
600 words per hour working class 750
professionals 2153 by HD the vocabulary
used by children and high SES homes is
larger than the vocabularies by parents
in the low SES by h3 larger vocabulary
this is just telling you the incredible
cumulative power of strong environmental
influences because it's unbelievably
multiplicative it's every day all day
long if you're in an environment that's
supportive or an environment that's not
okay every it's not one shot it's every
day multiply multiply multiply a 300
words more per hour for professional no
Offerman's extrapolate a year a child
and professional family here's 11
million words versus 3 million a welfare
family and strong correlation with IQ
scores by age 9 so very huge differences
in what children are exposed to at home
and they correlate highly with disease
things so there's an inch so the
literature is that on average on average
the IQ scores that children have around
nine or ten correlate pretty well with
ones that have for the rest of their
lives before that it's extremely jumps
around we don't know why but that's
that's just a finding that time you're
nine or ten whatever you have on average
tends to hang in there you know if
you're 100 at ten you'll tend to be 120
120 at ten you'll tend to be 120 or 20
so that makes sense okay you roughly so
there's been a lot of interest in
evidence about whether you can change
your IQ as an adult so here's one study
that got a lot of attention because it
was kind of interesting in that way so
they they did it they did a complicated
task like this where is this n-back task
the simultaneous you hear letters and
you see little spatial locations like
this and every time something matched
two items ago you would push a button so
you're hearing them at the same time and
if you hear a letter that was two
letters ago you push a button or same
spatial location you push one it's
pretty hard they took 34 adults they
trained them from 8 to 19 day so less
than a month
skipped weekends 25 minutes a day so
only half an hour day to train on this
and then they tested them on some of
these widely used IQ types of measures
here's a performance on the task itself
getting better and better okay that's
not surprising and the more they
practice the higher they got so if you
practice really hard at something you
get better at doing it that's that's not
the thing they were interested where
they were interested in this here's the
IQ scores before they were trained the
IQ scores they didn't practice the IQ
test and here's the IQ ones afterwards
this is the control group who did
nothing this is a group that the de
mental practice and you can see they
pushed up their IQ scores not a lot but
it was only 20 minutes a day for you
know less than a month so these are
these kinds of studies really intrigued
people in two ways and the more training
you got the more your IQ score went up
more weeks you do this because a you
know maybe we could push up IQ scores if
that's important to push up this is a
big decision even when you're an adult
you know what if you did more than 20
minutes a day for three weeks and B you
know maybe we could push up everybody's
IQ score who needed help in that with
the right kind of training
No at any age so a lot of interest in
that so let me let me take a step now to
sort of harder topics now one of the
reasons that intelligence and IQ topics
have gotten appropriately lots of
concern is there's a terrible history of
racism and sexism associated with IQ
tests and the way people use that to
argue basically inferiority of groups
other than themselves so the US
Immigration Act of 1924 the official
government talked about biologically
weak stocks at that time they were
prejudiced against their focus their
prejudice against Italians and Jews from
Europe okay different societies
different times as you know tragically
have biases against different groups in
the world they're just unfortunately
it's part of the world we live in you
know and even though we know now with
certainty that we're all almost
identical genetically in any practical
sense across racial groups race remains
a powerful social category right it's
very complicated topic you know the
experience you've had as experience
you've had but we know it's it's it's a
it's a social category people identify
to a certain extent with with that they
recognize other people in that context
we'll come back to that later in the
course but it's a sort of a fact of life
that we often think of ourselves as
belonging to one racial group or another
and somebody else's belonging to one
racial group or another so I'm going to
focus on one thing that's both trouble
people and litsa to bad things but but
has some interesting important aspects
to think about so in the u.s. when
people compare African American and
European American scores there's a gap
scores that grows over time so an
infancy
to the extent you can test these kinds
of things there's no difference by age
four on average people who are European
American will tend to score about four
or five points higher in IQ tests and as
the age goes up it continues to go up
there's a gap on average the huge
averages across many people so we're you
know that across time as people get
older in the US now we strongly believe
for many many reasons empirically that
this is an environmental influence and
here's one example of many pieces of
evidence so that children fathered for
example
but black American GIs and Germany
brought up by German mothers have
exactly the same IQs as white American
GIs children and German mother said is
in countries where stereotypes were not
applied in general because partly
because it wasn't a history of for
African Americans of Germany at that
time the IQ scores are the same so we
think it's you know overwhelmingly
evident that it's an environmental
effect but in the u.s. you know there's
a lot of relationship between on average
across the entire country on average
between what group you're in
and average income so here's the average
income a few years ago depending on
which group you identified yourself as
belonging to so we talked earlier about
the relationship between economic
comfort or stability or support and
things like the number of words a parent
can speak to or it's time to speak to
their child and how that seems to
correlate with all kinds of advantages
so here's an incredibly powerful and
important idea Claude Steele is a
researcher at Stanford who on you whose
play a big part in this and here's the
idea so it's called stereotype threat it
applies to all of us but but in some
ways depending on the world we live in
you know some of us can be more
vulnerable than others in certain
situations
here's the idea so let me tell you the
experiment and then the interpretation
the experiment is that he'll bring
people in and give Claude or students
black and white participants college
students and they say it's a laboratory
experiment and they give them something
like an SAT test and the group's perform
just the same okay Stanford students
black and white perform just the same
that's the one group here comes the next
group of black and white students who
are told we're going to give you a test
of intelligence now look what happens
the scores of African Americans go down
and it doesn't even have to be the
phrase test of intelligence you can have
people just tick off on a front page
what racial group they belong to and you
get almost the same effect so what is
this this is understood as stereotype
vulnerability that is tragically in the
u.s. there's a stereotype that African
Americans are not as good academically
as white Americans
it's a pernicious stereotype is when we
can decry more aliens it's a bad thing
but it's out there there's another area
where African Americans are thought of
as phenomenal by stereotype which is
sports in this country it's a weird
thing right okay most of us you know so
but it seemed but now the idea is that
knowledge of these things even if you
this is your real performance once that
thought enters your mind that I'm doing
something that some people say I'm not
going to do such a good job down is
enough to make you underperform compared
to your true potential so the other area
where this has been studied a lot it are
as women in mathematics I think that's
disappearing when I grew up everybody
was worried that women weren't given as
good an academic support as men or girls
and boys okay it's reversed okay in my
lifetime it's reversed because now by
every criteria women are outperforming
men in the u.s. by every criteria but
they societally the number who finished
school you're beginning salaries
everything okay so now they're worried
that us boys are really being left
behind okay so it's these things change
because they're cultural inventions okay
they're cultural inventions and cultural
mores change and sometimes in good ways
hopefully so stereotypes right is that
that that others judgments are one's own
actions will confirm negative
stereotypes of one's group oh York's you
should do badly on something we should
do well on something so they studied on
women that old people you know almost
like athletic ability of course once the
opposites the experiment was kind of fun
they had a very athletic
african-american instructor come up and
start doing push-ups and all the white
guys started - laps in their push-ups
they got tired really fast compared to
of an equally athletic white trainer
came up to the front does that make
sense okay good does that make sense
okay it's whatever whatever is the
stereotype you have in your head you
know if you say okay oh I'm not supposed
to do good in this you underperform not
everybody all the time of course but
enough that we should we have to be
concerned about that you know more for
academic performance probably than
push-ups but who knows all right so
here's this achievement gap and here so
here you know there's different scores
between again at age
between whites and blacks in the United
States which we know shouldn't be there
many factors are in it a huge variation
among people of course he's a huge
averages but one that you know everybody
wants to get rid of in a just society
where everybody has an equal opportunity
so here's something unbelievable result
it's so unbelievable that if it weren't
for some subsequent results I wouldn't
even show it to you even though it's
well done experiment but the message of
it seems so incredible ok so here's what
they did in this wealth control studying
science and there's been some follow-ups
that have exactly done this so they took
on African American students and white
students and they had them you know take
these various tests but some of them at
the beginning of the year wrote an
affirmation they had they had to choose
a value from a list and write an
in-class essay about why the chosen
value is important to you the controls
chose a value from the same list and
we're an essay about why the value might
be important for somebody else you're
writing a one time essay about why
something matters to you or matters to
somebody else so obviously what matters
to you is more powerful for you right
and by just doing that there's a 40%
reduction in the African American
students in the study and their
achievement grab their scores went up
40% because they wrote one essay at the
beginning of the year about why values
are important to them and related to
education one essay did that okay
unbelievable and just a reminder about
how much one's attitude incredibly
influences your performance you have a
range of things you can do and what gets
you to the top of your range that's in
you or the bottom of your range has a
lot to do with attitudes that can be
moved around by a lot of things one
essay overcame a tremendous amount of
the concerns that on average African
American students have about academic
achievement and it's not just that so
I'm you know in this course you only get
a couple of tips of things that are
useful to you for courses here's one
okay it's the same principle but it
seems to apply for everybody especially
okay so here's the experiment also
published in science is really cool so
I'm they brought in the brought in
students and they said look look
students often are worried about how
they're going to do in a test especially
if it's an area you think you're not
so good in okay so they had to take a
test on Gauss's modular arithmetic
here's the pretest everybody did about
the same then they said okay now they
have to create pressure because of
course if you take a test in an
experiment that's not pressure right
pressure is the grade you're going to
get whether it lets you into medical
school whether you get to become the
head of the American Medical Association
right okay
that's pressure right all right so they
say oh here's what we're going to do now
we're going to give you another test
everybody's scoring about the same but
you can make a fair bit of money with a
partner who's down the hall we should
tell you that partner has already done a
really good job on the second version of
the test so if you don't do well you
don't get money and the partner down the
hall doesn't get your money okay if you
do well on the second test you're about
to take now then everybody wins so
they're trying to make you feel
pressured oh man I want to win the money
plus there's a guy down the hall who
already did well and I'm gonna let it
let us down right they're trying to make
you feel as pressured as you might as
much as they can in an experiment like
you do in a regular test in a regular
course alright so trying to create
pressure and anxiety okay and then for
10 minutes the controls just sit there
and think about it oh I hope you know I
don't mess up now the pressures on I
don't meet the person if I don't do a
good job down the hall all right okay an
expressive group wrote an essay for ten
minutes about their thoughts and
feelings I wrote this back and this is a
huge mistake this should be better okay
I'll fix it up better better better I
did it unrelated in writing so here's
what happens the group that just sat
there did nothing on their performance
does it let me get this right the
performance that wrote the expressive
writing the score goes up everybody
else's scores go down because here the
users are beginning now they get
pressured and they perform less well
right the pressure is you know they're
choking okay the group that wrote the
essay their performance stays up and
it's kind of ironic because there's a
theme of comic of comedy it's frequently
when they tell you whatever you do don't
tell somebody X and then by mistake you
tell X have you seen that in a comedy
show okay all right all right so you
could have thought or writing an essay
about my thoughts and feelings about how
much anxiety and pressure I feel
it's like the worst thing you can do
it's like I don't want to face it you
know I'd rather clear my mind right but
it turns out that when people write this
little essay about their thoughts and
feelings about their anxiety their
scores rise and if they don't write that
kind of an essay the scores fall because
you've introduced here the stress and
anxiety that we think is a part of
regular testing that makes sense I'll
fix the slide I'm sorry about the typo
all right okay so I'm a little afraid to
give you advice because if somebody will
write an essay to bet on the physics
test and say oh this is terrible I would
have got an A but it seems like writing
as a little essay about your thoughts
and feelings actually pushes scores up I
mean that's the scientific evidence but
again it's just a reminder of how
powerful feelings and attitudes are
whether they're in us or visited on us
by the world in how well we perform
within the range of performance that we
eat they're within us to start with I've
two more points so we talked a little
bit about entity versus growth you know
people who believe that like I'm only so
good at something
I'm only so good at basketball only so
good at math I'm only this programming
I'm only so good at writing or whatever
versus people who say the harder I work
the better I'll get and that pretty much
this work from Carol Dweck that many
people tend to you know go for one thing
or the other or is it are we born with
talents and that's pretty much the deal
or the harder we work do we get more
talented at doing something and so this
is a kind of question there's a
literally question so she gives students
you have a certain amount of
intelligence and you really can't change
it you know I strongly agree that's
that's this straight model or I disagree
the harder I work the more I can smarter
I can be so and what she did for example
is give that kind of questionnaire to
students and then follow them in the
performance and a math course here's the
ones who believed they could get better
here's the ones who said they only have
so much math ability and intelligence
and look at the ones who thought they
could get better it got better so that
seems like a really good thing to have
is also not only the positive attitude
but you know a real belief that the
harder the work the smarter you'll get
um all right last two slides so finally
finally finally and we've had a couple
of them but almost no
a longitudinal random assignment study
okay which sound doesn't sound usually
exciting but that's the best science we
can ever do randomly assign people to
things and the follow them over time to
understand how life works so one of the
famous studies is which is for this
Perry preschool so it followed into
adulthood 123 children from low SES
environments and around in Michigan and
they were randomly andum we divided and
there's no randomness right in life
mostly you're not randomly given genes
you're not randomly put into a household
it's always the things are super
correlated with each other and it's very
hard to tease them apart but here they
took kids who are from poor families and
put them randomly into two groups one
group is a program group who received
high-quality active learning preschool
program and home visits to be supportive
as well so they got help at home and
help it's in preschool and an O program
group who didn't get any of these I can
tell you that when you do random
assignment studies in real life like
this some people said some people argue
I don't agree this that it's unethical
because you should help everybody all
the time but if you don't do this you
never figure out what helps people's
okay so it's a little bit of a circuit
you know you know you can't you can't
figure out what really helps people okay
so anyway and then in a really rare
thinks that's random assignment they
follow them ages three to eleven
fourteen to fifteen nineteen twenty
seven and forty okay
like they follow you through most of
your childhood and adult life so what
happens here's their IQ scores here's
the program people in red at the no
program people in blue and you can see
that for a few years they separate by IQ
but by age seven they're pretty much the
same and when these kind of data came
out there because now they of course
after the preschool they go back to the
regular local schools - pretty much the
same schools okay so people have said
after that they said well the Head Start
as a kind of a program to help kids who
are poor get a head start in education
and support it's no good it doesn't do
anything because once they get back into
schools that are not very supportive the
benefits of the program disappear you
didn't do anything for the kid because
unless you fix everything in their law
is that one year just doesn't make a
difference in the long run okay so
everybody said Head Start programs are
just a sad lis a waste of resources
because they don't do anything for these
children over the longer term but here's
the remarkable thing
they kept following these kids and
here's what they found for example in
the number of arrests 36 had had five or
more arrests in the program group but in
that in the in the but all the way up to
55 for the no program group that's a big
difference how often you're arrested
that's a big outcome in life right
earning 20,000 or more at age 40 program
group sixty percent no program rule
forty percent completed high school 45
to 65 twenty percent increase in
completion of high school from one year
of help before kindergarten basic
achievement at age fourteen way up
homework no willingness to do homework
way up okay so so what's that's telling
us is you know IQ is a pretty
interesting thing and we talk a lot
about it is an interesting thing but
there's something really deep in the
ways you can help people that make them
you know succeed in life you know not
get in trouble avoid bad things make
money finish school do your work okay
that one year of school change these
kids for the rest of their lives and on
average you know and imagine if you had
done two years or five years you know
alright so and IQ in this case doesn't
capture it at all
there's something else in them that
changed that made them more resilient in
life and successful in the long run so
there's a lot of pieces to who does well
not well in ways we wish for everybody
and IQs a piece of that story but
there's a lot of pieces so thanks very
much
you
you